Yesterday I asked on Twitter at d Pacman,
you should be following me.
By the way, what stories should I definitely
cover on tomorrow's show?
That being today's program, and I got a bunch
of people who said, David, you have to talk
about how right-wing host Ben Shapiro is saying
he doesn't believe Brett Cavanaugh's accusers
because they haven't described Brett Cavanaugh's
penis, which I assumed that can't really be
what Ben Shapiro said, but alas, it is.
And the reason I'm covering this, this is
not just another wacky thing Ben Shapiro said,
although it is yet another wacky thing that
Ben Shapiro said, there's actually more to
this.
So let's, let's set it up.
Uh, Brett Cavanagh has been accused again
of sexual assault.
Trump is off the rails tweeting about it.
I told you about that earlier this week and
incomes.
Ben Shapiro.
And he says, the reason that he doubts the
veracity of the allegations is that if Kavanaugh
had really sexually assaulted anyone, the
victims would have been able to describe Brett
Cavanaugh's penis in detail by now.
This apparently counts as an argument in some
circles.
Chick, take a look at the video, check it
out.
We've had a bevy of public figures in recent
years who have had their genitalia described
on national television.
My people who alleged sexual assault, right?
Stormy Daniels famously described president
Trump's genitalia, Bill Clinton, his genitalia,
details of such were, were talked about.
Nobody has yet described cabinet as Janet.
Now that's not as positive and maybe they
were generic, who knows?
But the bottom line is we've had no corroborating
details on any of these stories.
All of them apparently happened in public
places with other witnesses available and
not one witness has been there.
Who corroborates any of these stories?
It's unbelievable.
And yet the Democrats are still saying that
Kavanaugh should be kicked off the supreme
court based on what a new report from a guy
who says that he was at a party and saw a
male grab cabinets, penis, which by the way,
it would be sexual assault and then thrust
it into the hand of a female who says she
doesn't remember the incident.
It's so crazy that this is the argument that
Ben Shapiro is making for why he doesn't believe
the allegations against Brett [inaudible].
It's almost like he doesn't know how sex works.
And I know he must because he has children,
right?
I mean, I don't know much about his personal
life, but as far as I know, the humans that
he calls, his kids are biologically his kids.
And as far as, as far as I would guess, they
were conceived in sort of the normal way.
So you would imagine he knows how sex works.
I can't believe I'm doing this, but there
are a few problems with this argument from
Ben Shapiro.
First of all, of course, is that incidents
that happen at parties, sexual assaults, all
of this stuff, many of these things happen
in dark places like this.
This is so rudimentary and fundamental, but
from a logistical perspective, if something
happens in a dark place, you may not have
been able to look at identifying marks on
Brett Cavanaugh's genitalia.
Uh, that doesn't really seem like a big deal.
It's not a big counterpoint to any of the
accusers.
Number two in incidents of trauma victims
are often not focusing on, let me see if there
are moles or birthmarks or skin discolorations
on Brett Cavanaugh's genitalia.
They're scared for their lives, they're being
assaulted and their priority likely is survival
and getting away.
So once again, not having in mind particular
characteristics of Brett Kavanaugh is penis
does not seem to be material in this case.
And then maybe most importantly, this is a
specious argument argument because if you
can even call it an argument, if a woman did
describe Brett Cavanaugh's penis in her allegation,
the defenders would just come up with some
other way to dismiss that point.
And I was actually reminded of Michael Jackson,
Michael Jackson's peanut, Michael Jackson,
of course, the late pop star who had multiple
allegations of child sexual assault against
him.
Michael Jackson's penis was described by accusers
and defenders just came up with excuses.
I don't remember exactly what the excuses
were, but listen, if someone describes cabin
Oz penis, they could say, well, someone could
have told them how to describe it.
There could be a doctor with knowledge of
his penis who is involved in the conspiracy
or it was a lucky guess or with Jackson.
Jackson was known to have video Lygo the skin
condition.
So it would be just a safe guessed to say
that his penis also had discolorations because
it's known that he had vitiligo or whatever
the point is, you can always defend it.
Someone describes Cavanaugh's penis.
Well, they could have been in cahoots with
a doctor who saw it once or the description
was too generic or it's not accurate in some
minute irrelevant way or whatever.
And by the way, I think the, let me link this
back now beyond Ben Shapiro to really, what
is the, the, the issue the media focus on
Cavanaugh's behavior in high school and college
instead of his lying to Congress.
And his extraordinarily suspicious financial
transactions may at the higher level be both
misguided and counterproductive.
But that's a completely different story.
So there's the analysis from Ben Shapiro,
he wants the penis described in detail or
he is going to, uh, skeptical of the allegations
that have been made.
It's a, this is 2019, and this is, this is
the world that we live in today.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you like the David Pakman show on
Facebook at facebook.com/david Pakman show.
Coming up next, a judge has been permanently
barred
from the bench for posting a pro Trump nag
a message with a picture of
a news.
Nice, right?
We'll talk about that
after the break.